so tonight I'm hanging out with my
friend Nigel and he's brought along one
of his science toys a little white
plastic ball um actually a white plastic
ball at all you told me you were
bringing the white plastic ball tonight
it's not what color would you call that
I would call it purple it's a purple
ball
purple really yeah you see purple I you
know I'm not good with colors I don't
know if you want me to say fuchsia but
it's you know it's purple well it's
interesting you say that there is
lighting it but it is actually a red
blue and green light but it looks purple
no that's definitely a red blue and
green light in there all right well how
are we gonna settle this debate I can
show you that it is red blue and green
are you gonna do that um by twirling it
in a circle simple
you're gonna twirl that in a circle and
all of a sudden I'm gonna say that it's
red blue and green I promise you nothing
less okay it's a pretty good promise
let's uh let's see it all right Wow okay
so I'm not too big of a person to admit
when I'm wrong and I see a red green and
blue balls around the the outside of the
circle but when you slow it down it it
goes back to being purple
yeah it's um actually everyone will see
it being purple because the red blue and
green lights are turning on and off so
quickly after each other that your brain
actually merges it into one color when
the ball is in one place so the I
actually kind of holds the information
there about what color it's seeing for
an instant longer than it's there and it
merges together to prove that purple
color yeah that red blue and green kind
of merge to this dusty violet color
dusty violet of the vial you know your
colors should be a paint on wide can we
see them separate it when you swirl it
in a circle when I swirl it in a circle
I'm actually getting the ball to switch
colors to red to green to blue at
different points in space so at
different points in space your eye is
not actually holding that image as it
switches to a different color right so
even if the eye remembers the color that
it's seen it's not going to merge with
the next color because that occurs at a
different point in space exactly so it's
much easy to see the red blue and green
Lots happening in the ball than it is
when it's still so can you think
of some practical applications for this
I cannot compress a lot of fun for a
Saturday night out right a lot of fun
for a set it not out and I am in a dark
alley yeah so try that at your next
party next party trick yeah that's a
good pun trick all right well let's go a
lot of parties as you can see let's go
crash some parties we're gonna be a big
hit with this thing
high five I'm not surprised that no one
wanted to be interviewed by us oh I am
this is awesome this is awesome this is
awesome I guess